o sea fx igual a un medio de x al cubo
más 13 x menos cuatro y sea h la inversa
de la función
efe observa que f de menos 2 es menos 14
y lo que nos piden es que encontremos h
prima en menos 14 si no estás muy
familiarizado con cómo se relacionan las
derivadas de las funciones inversas con
esas funciones esto puede sonar como
algo muy complicado porque no es tan
sencillo encontrar la función inversa de
un polinomio de grado 3 pero aquí hay un
truco muy bueno en realidad de lo que te
tienes que dar cuenta en este ejercicio
es que el hecho de que h y f sean
funciones inversas hace que h prima de x
sea igual a 1 entre
efe prima de h de x entonces podemos
utilizar esto para encontrar cuánto es h
prima de menos 14 ahora me imagino lo
que tú estás pensando en estos momentos
porque es lo que yo pensaría si alguien
de repente sacará una fórmula como estas
de la nada esto de dónde sale bueno pues
esto sale directamente de la regla de la
cadena por la regla de la cadena sabemos
que si tenemos una función f evaluada en
su función inversa ok vih son funciones
inversas sabemos que esto es igual a
equis también podríamos poner h de fx y
también nos quedaría x recuerda si f y h
son inversas h va a mandar a la equis a
algún valor llamado hdx pero como f y h
son inversas entonces
efe si le evaluamos en ese valor hdx
va a regresar a ese valor otra vez a
equis y viceversa eso es lo que
significa que dos funciones sean
inversas esto de aquí es cierto porque f
y h son funciones inversas pero ahora si
tomamos la derivada de estos dos
términos si tomamos la derivada con
respecto a x de estos términos me
imagino que ya tienes una muy buena idea
de que estamos haciendo aquí vamos a
obtener una versión de esta fórmula para
realizar esta derivada tenemos que usar
la regla de la cadena y obtenemos f
prima f prima evaluada en hd x h de x
por la derivada de hd x o sea h prima de
x
tiene que ser igual a la derivada con
respecto de x de x entonces de este lado
nos va a quedar simplemente un 1 y ahora
nada más tenemos que dividir ambos lados
/ efe prima de hd x y obtenemos la
fórmula de acá pero bueno ya que vimos
de donde salió esta fórmula vamos a
aplicarla lo que queremos encontrar en
este ejercicio es h prima de menos 14
por lo que tenemos aquí nosotros sabemos
que h prima de menos 14 es igual a 1
/ efe prima de hd menos 14 h de menos 14
y ahora podemos preguntarnos si en la
información que nos dieron viene cuánto
es hd menos 14 y claro que si nos dieron
esa información no explícitamente pero
por aquí está la respuesta a nosotros no
se nos debe de olvidar que f
y h son funciones inversas entonces si
efe - 2 es menos 14 f está mandando
menos 2 a menos 14 y como h es la
inversa tiene que mandar menos 14 a
menos 2 si a h le damos el valor menos
14 nos tiene que dar menos 2 y esto es
porque h y f son funciones inversas hd
menos 14 tiene que ser menos 2 si
tenemos una función inversa lo que hace
es intercambiar estos dos valores del
lugar
si f va de menos 2 a menos 14 h tiene
que ir de menos 14 a menos 2 simplemente
los voltea bueno y ahora queremos
encontrar cuánto es f prima en menos 2 y
para eso tenemos que encontrar a efe
prima
si es que f prima de x es igual a aquí
vamos a tener que usar la regla de las
potencias tenemos un medio por x a la 3
así es que tomamos el exponente
multiplicamos por el coeficiente y nos
queda 3 medios por x a la 3 - 1
o sea x a la 2 más la derivada de 3x lo
cual es simplemente 3 y esto lo podemos
ver sencillamente como la regla de las
potencias también aquí está x
implícitamente está elevada a la
potencia 1 y entonces nos queda uno por
por equis elevada a la 11 o sea x a la 0
pero x a la cero es 1 así es que nos
queda 3 por 13 y luego la derivada de
una constante es simplemente cero
entonces ya tenemos
efe prima de x por lo que podemos
encontrar fácilmente f prima de menos 2
esto es igual a tres medios por menos 2
al cuadrado que es simplemente 4 3
34 entre dos es 2 y nos queda 3 por 2
639 por lo que este denominador
efe prima de menos 2 es igual a 9 y
entonces h prima de menos 14 es un
noveno y listo ya terminamos no vas a
encontrarte este tipo de problemas en tu
vida diaria pero es un problema típico
de cálculo y está bastante interesante